I want to describe this next result just because it just shows how weird
computational complexity results can be.
Let's think about the colorability of planar graphs. In particular, here's a decision problem.
We're given a graph G and a number K. Is planar graph G K colorable?
And let's look at how the difficulty of the question differs as we change K. So K is 1.
What kind of graphs are K colorable? Graphs with no edges.
So we can answer this question in constant time if the number of edges is greater than 0, no.
As soon as there is a single edge, then you're going to need to two colors to color the nodes in that.
All right. What if it's two? We want to know if this graph two colorable.
We'll you know this one already because two colorability is exactly the same as testing
whether the graph is bipartite and in the previous unit, you showed that that could be solved
with depth-first search and therefore, runs in big Θ(n+m).
In case three, well 3 colorability we showed was NP complete,
but we didn't do that for planar graphs, we did that for general graphs.
but it turns out that you can actually introduce another gadget into the mix here
that actually let you deal with edge crossings.
So if you have a piece of the graph that looks like this and there's a crossing in it,
you can actually introduce some nodes here so that the information from this node travels along
and gets to this node without ever having to cross another edge.
It becomes a planar graph. I didn't explain how to do this but it turns out to be true.
A three coloring of planar graph isn't any easier
than three coloring in general graph, it's NP complete.
What about coloring a graph with four colors if its a planar graph.
Well, remarkably, the problems gotten harder and harder from constant to linear
to basically it seems like it requires exponential time, it goes back to constant time,
and that's because of the celebrated 4-color map theorem that says that any map
can be colored with four colors and in this particular case, any map can be translated
into a planar graph and so we know that every planar graph can be colored with four colors.
So the constant time algorithm for this problem is just to always say yes.
You give me a graph and tell me this is planar and I say, "Yup, it's four colorable,"
and therefore, it's also going to be five, six, seven colorable because you can just use the first four.
So that's kind of cool. So one of the things to point out is that the peak of the hardness comes at K=3.
That actually shows up a lot in NP complete problems.
Usually if there's two of something that you have to choose from,
the problem is pretty easy because you can try one of them
and if it doesn't work try the other one right away, but when if there's three,
you have to keep considering lots of different combinations of things and
the difficulty level really, really blows up.